ما الذي حدث للفئران بالضبط تمكن العلماء
من تحديد عمري انسجه المخ والعينين
والعضلات والجلد والكلى لدى الفئران
وابتكر ديفيد سيكلر خبير مكافحه الشيخوخه
واستاذ علم الوراثه مزيجا لما حقنه في
الخلايا التالفه في عيون الفئران العمياء
وتم تغطيتها بالمضادات الحيويه النتائج
كانت مذهله
فقرارها ويعد ذلك الرجل الفريق خلايا
الدماغ والعضلات والكلى واعادها الى
مستويات اصغر بكثير واليوم يحاول فريق
البحث هذا طريقه لتوصيل التبديل الجيني
بالتساوي لكل خليه وبالتالي تجديد شباب
الفقر دي اكمله
قد تمر عقود قبل ان تبدا اي تجارب اكديكيه
لمكافحه الشيخوخه على البشر واذا كانت
امنه وناجحه يتم توزيعها الى الحجم
المطلوب للموافقه الفيدراليه